[Music]
hello hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to we happy
few hope you guys are doing wonderfully
out there
hope you guys are lovely and happy I
remember what I said last time about not
being actually happy I'm going to punch
you in the taint so don't trust don't
don't test me I will I'm very punchy
today so welcome back to we happy few we
are going to be picking up exactly where
we left off right away no pretense no
nothing sneaking allows you to move
selves late but don't get spotted no one
likes a lurker well I'm not gonna be a
lurker I'm gonna be a stab people in the
face kind of guy because that's exactly
who I need to be and that's exactly who
I want to be so hey how's it going
everybody probably not gonna post here
because posts are gone in like two
seconds well unfortunately for you that
was the one that I saw of you so there
you have it so and welcome everybody
else how can you send me fan art I don't
know through the various social media
channels that I have
it's kind of hard these days but there's
also still that old deviantART page so
if you want to go to that that is a
perfectly valid way of doing it yeah
don't forget to upgrade oh yeah I forgot
to upgrade you're well fed you will wait
hey I thought I was it wasn't at the
fort wasn't I had that fort and whatever
okay so we're gonna go and we're gonna
upgrade some stuff we've got 1313 good
god but I just got squishy sweet dreams
I thought I just got that okay here to
the ground those footsteps from further
away nah I want the I want the iron fist
and then pack a wallop
I want the pack a wallop then bloody
hell I guess and then blockbuster yeah
what about this frying pan one oh you
need to get this to be able to get dad
some weapons now cause damage to
subsequent targets okay I don't know
what I'm gonna be doing that but I need
to get this to get the slap chop so
gotta go that by that skill super duper
I don't care about that let me get the
slap chopped by am ok Slap Chop
a healthier mommy yeah I guess that's
useful a little preparation you can give
oh so I can hold can I hold my punchy's
Oh that'd be pretty useful okay
block party or well time block with a
weapon can knock your enemy down okay
well that's nice okay easy enough right
what about anything else
there's no item upgrades in this game oh
god you can't see Oh God
ah there was now bye guys ah why am I
trusted to be able to do anything right
why am i trusted to be able to do
anything at all why am I just why am I
allowed to make videos on the internet
if I can't freaking do the most
basically I forget that so much I forget
it all the time every single moment of
every single life I have is spent doing
that and it's just so stupid Oh children
all right everyone just forget forget
that happen to forget that was the way
that that went down pretend like I
actually know what I'm doing and I
actually have an idea of what I'm doing
in my life and where I'm going and just
please just give me a chance I swear I
swear I actually do know what I'm doing
and no no no man just please just let me
be let me be alright here we go back in
the game again I guess
oh we doing going Oh behave did the
salamanca bridge well what did freaking
do we're off here to the first time that
we ever did this before why is this like
this everything is going wrong I was
having a lovely day and everything was
just totally fine now everything is
wrong okay let's go we got to go off to
the bridge why I thought I was well fed
what do I need to munch on some stuff
what do I have to munch on probably
nothing right I have a ball of rancid
stew well that can't do anything worse
than I've already done to myself so I'm
gonna eat that Oh Oh bull fighting got
some tea to make me throw up
huh wait how long is that gonna be oh
god I don't even know what next amide is
what's next too much sick up T all right
well let's vomit I guess no oh all right
well we're all good here
I guess I'm I guess is this that's all
good I guess that's how we're gonna play
this we started this and then
immediately threw up and then everything
is good
don't eat the bad food well you know I
can't keep doing this well you got to
keep doing this why is there a big heart
on that hmm I don't like to look at that
all behave walk your way past the Bobby
oh hi hello constable right let me just
search an ear real quick hey buddy
unfortunately the bridge is not open at
least I'm ah it was working just a
minute ago but the door is broken again
you left the white and city's up again
do you ever let anybody now yes there's
someone in there now and in the past
month in the past month
ah this is chappy there right now you
don't really want anyone back from the
garden district do you well my wife's
girlfriend
no one goes off there joy can actually
take your way on main would you yes I
would he feels better that door stays
broken do us everybody right I suppose
now I can tell central why the bridge
keeps breaking down central never seen
one of these um Barker may you know some
sort of undercover bridge inspector
yeah this means detect structural
irregularities using short wave radar
yeah I don't think it will show me the
real problem we all right sir you can
fix that door but then wastrels still
ain't gonna take that joy in make some
seat wise
everywhere that's not for you to decide
is it not sure that the maintenance
hatch is that wiser I heard I'd be
grateful if you forgot this conversation
ever ever happened maybe I won't maybe I
won't I hit my head real good the other
day I fell down an elevator from an old
general that didn't know what the hell
he was talking about but you sir you're
in luck cuz Mike I've got a severe
blamed a blues and I'm gonna wave my
magical device and see what happens here
why is there a big heart here by the way
do you have any understanding of why
that is that way I'm a read newspaper
now I'm concealed you can't see me
anyway back to what I was saying you're
an idiot and I have no idea what your
name even is anymore what am i doing I
don't even know where do I go literally
I don't
well climbed up on that you impressed oh
the door who defied the door would have
been the place where the door oh if I
really was from central I'd have the
card wouldn't I
there is another way I wasn't there I
don't know about that ah there's another
way I could I could jump you want me to
jump you jump jump jump jump jump ah
come on I can't jump to my death
Oh what's the fun of even playing a
video game I can't leap to my demise was
that wait who take your joy what is that
why Sir
what sit down here whoa whoa hang on
wait a second I gotta go leap off a
mountain
yeah I'll all right why are you down
there
ow why are you are you down there I'll
get you I'm gonna get you it's gonna be
worth it worth it was it worth it
yes sudden death who for after
overexerting himself swimming well [ __ ]
I guess I'm dead now why was there a
night blossom down there if I wasn't
supposed to go get it oh god oh
what kind of crazy are they telling me
that I was not supposed to do that all
right fine and the undiscovered country
from whose Bourn no traveler returns
what the hell are you talkin about man
you spouting poetry over here listen I'm
not exactly an educated man I dropped
out of engineering school well that was
about a hundred meters so you know
that's about the same all right let's
keep going there's nobody else here they
take a number and sit down okay at Saint
Genesis spare sovereigns can I take
these spare for me spare for me please
number okay number two to return to
Hamlin village warning it's past curfew
we need curfew all right what are you
doing up past curfew huh all right I'll
just be just resting the future just as
a movie
[Music]
what happens if you wait what would
happen if you wait that's me I'm doing
habilitation Center thank you actually
I'm just a sort of undercover bridge
inspector from central see this device
it detects structural then you should
have no trouble passing the test should
you yes head through the door there and
begin your rehabilitation
okay I don't know that there was some
setups to be rehabilitated are you gonna
do the rehabilitation yourself someone's
awfully jiggly over there I don't I
don't think they're taking their gyre
whose ruse whose jiggling up a storm
over there
I don't like what I see whatever
rehabilitate me I'm ready to be
rehabilitated
hello rehabilitation oval last time I
was in an elevator I ended up killing a
killing several people
what's with the buttholes alright
whatever sure do love when I walk into a
room full of sphincters and what if I
don't what if I put my clothes in there
what if I go butt naked into this that
would show how rehabilitate
right yeah I'm sorry about Lillet ated
look at my dick look how rehabilitated
it is alright that's naked oh don't mind
if I do well you give me some teeth make
me throw up pick me up that hurdle I do
into the oh hey lady here's my dick how
are you doing oh I am getting naked ah
excuse me do you not want it I got naked
a little early anyway probably me
squatting down like this ain't exactly
the most attractive thing but nice to
meet you my name's mark how you doing
here's my dick anyway moving right along
and they take a little sippy did it be
too messy
I just got Promenade in about wondering
why everyone was staring he never did
quite grasp what's so important about
wearing clothes please please wash all
bits I go up there doing a handstand my
legs splayed out above me trying to get
as many jets into my butthole as
possible
hey buddy here anyway here's my yeah I
like how I was joking what were you
watching watching judging oh Jesus God
well I mean I'm not I'm not shy about
nothing Oh a magical voice later here's
my dick I washed all my bits including
my grundle how is the fun part
alright Walter did D I'm naked naked so
very naked let me through the bought
hole I can fit something through I can
just manage it out I already made me a
proper suit though I was wearing a
proper suit alright fine whatever
[Music]
refreshing scent country flowers ah hang
on a second I didn't realize there was
cloth scraps here that I could gather up
and I'm gonna just make sure I got all
the la-de-da-de-da washing my clothes
here to get clean another little dude
dude you all right buddy little nudity
let me grab this how about a sock okay
and a septic bandage where are those
things buried in there what did it do
I'm still naked here's my dick little
itty some clever censorship with the
with oh there's another one with the
newspaper there all right fine I guess
I'm not naked whatever ah Jewish
favorite flavor of joy chocolate oh wow
but I already got naked and now is my
favorite moment anyway can I get some
joy please ooh that shower
being naked washing that intensely
directly on my grundle that was a
challenge so I just gotta you know I
just got to relax a little bit anyway
doo doo doo doo doo boo boo boo I I must
insist that you not traverse the beams
of the Georgia Tech ho well no Tami I
was serious about taking more joy wasn't
they well what is that guy dead
wait whoa why don't you this what you
just kill him
why did you kill him what I have I have
some complaints to say to the management
[Music]
all right so um Oh someone's playing a
game of peekaboo over there oh all right
well uh anyway um how you doing
right is right like is right right is
rain rain is right and right you're
right lovely right as rain right as rain
right as rain right as rain
lovely weather well you not gonna talk
about the rain when I ask about the
weather right you are
that's you I know you by your face you
you man I know you right lovely day for
it
lovely day how about you how about you
have are you lovely day for it alright
okay uh you guys know what I have to do
right oh I can't save here well [ __ ]
here we go oh boy that's this that
smarts a little bit well I guess I'm
good can I go through I guess I'm fine
well huh whoo that was a doozy anyway
let me through now um anyway
oh that's not gonna hit me from here is
it okay good right is Ryan right as rain
nothing weird about what just happened
there Oh what happened to your mat what
what what
what
should clear up soon I imagine
oh um it's gonna pop behind the bar grab
this D that's not weird at all
that's totally normal Lily the truth has
a cost is right Ross is right where is
the joy where the Chris where is it what
kind of Art Deco is this what kind of a
glow today I just got out of a literal
hell hole I'm rehabilitated I washed my
taint and hey how you doing there pal Oh
anyway where's this goddamn joy Oh was
it oh it's in the mood booth well I
guess I gotta take it right I did well I
didn't even pick well I didn't know I
didn't want I wanted some else I wanted
chocolate
oh all right joy makes you happy but be
careful not to take too much the joy
meter will keep track of your joy
experimentation if the joyful meter
fills you will overdose and suffer
penalties the combat cramping and
conformity until the overdose passes as
you take more joy you will notice a
memory loss counter around the joy meter
this counter tracks your memory loss
from taking joy too many times when this
meter is full you will crash and suffer
severe penalties for this reason you
should use joy tactfully tactically and
only when necessary okay can I get some
chalk a lot yeah it's how it works
dude don't die but I do I love the
finger gun for you lady how about you to
give me some more I want more please
shove it in my mouth
maybe my but you got joy suppositories
look
hey you're dead just don't mind me
stealing your [ __ ] can I carry your body
why not
anyway look it up dude look keep my eyes
open
this room is for showing Uncle Jack only
it is not for other activities use the
Cody cozy cottages if you must there
talk about masturbation
huh nope dude let it we're gonna pop a
squat right over here oh no reason
oh yes please teach now it's time
Wow maybe wondering how can I fit in I
don't know it's easy to get along go
along if someone tells you it's a lovely
day agree with them because of course
it's always a lovely day and having
village so don't be afraid of talking to
people first they'll appreciate it now
I'm assuming of course that you were
decently dressed yeah
clothes make the man a indeed naked
people have almost no influence at all
in society don't dress in rags either or
people might think you're a wastrel
now what should you do if people are
staring at you maybe they're asking you
if you remember to take your joy okay
just pop another and they'll
congratulate you and go on about their
day okay and if things seem to be
getting a bit hectic remember you can
always sit on the bench relax and open
the handle Oh Quran take a load off no
one will bother you when you're sitting
on a bench unless you've made the very
angry yeah oh I do watch Jack Worthing
on television he's very good haha LM
afraid to catch the end of our time tune
in tomorrow for another etiquette minute
with Jack Worthing that's me okay
now please proceed to the third floor
where you will be tested on what you've
just learned mmm really okay dude
they're bibbidi I certainly didn't jack
off in that seat
wasn't me her little ugly dog going to
the cozy cottages for that sort of [ __ ]
hey Robert Bay some people don't like
paper what is running jumping Gretchen
spying sneaking breaking or entering
such like behaviour is what we associate
with Danner's avoidance okay all right
you got it buddy
also you're tall oh you're standing
looks like for everybody I see the cozy
cottages oh god that is awful I know for
sure glad he's still around if you wanna
fit in you should say hello so everyone
you me me
visit people judges over there or not
[Laughter]
say hello
visit eyes I like eyes I like eyes eyes
are the window to the soul did you know
that was my answer why does everything
else that's a good question don't you
steal my answer I know you're cheating
off of me you Sam [ __ ] that's my answer
don't you dare don't you [ __ ] dare
you [ __ ] dare you even freaking dare
but that's what I asked
if I say you're running beat me in the
face smash you're in the vise that's fun
play with yourself okay I like to
playing with yourself look I like to
playing with yourself if there's one
thing I always say it's always playing
with yourself whenever you get a chance
don't you take my answer you sack of
[ __ ] we want you to succeed that time
you didn't steal my answer aren't you in
the eyes now your eyes out
why is everything staring why is this
goddamn robot staring at me why is this
horrifying horrible robot staring at me
why are you staring at me I see you over
there
don't thing I don't know you guys you
get too happy
who cares I think you too cares cuz
honestly who cares okay okay who cares
who cares right is that the right answer
I did it I did it kick your ass Oh
all right I pass heylia know what quick
but my past you say I pass you said I
pass this again give me that [ __ ]
where's my [ __ ] who what's this they
gave me the metal bits can i BAP you in
the head a bap
about bleep Louise has that guy just
been there forever
the guy just not leaving oh well hey bad
dude perfect
pneumatic stash oh it's the stash E
thing okay duct tape
that's good can I sleep now I'm not
gonna sleep waste bin nah nothing there
cupboard okay TV oh now that's nice oh
god I couldn't feel better could you
okay all right well all right hello oh
hi may i express my delight that you
passed the examination sir we've not add
as many as we'd hoped sir
not as many at all and yet they say the
unexamined life is not worth living well
sir welcome back
oh and in case your rustic ation has
been of long duration please bear in
mind there is now a nocturnal curfew
based be indoors after nightfall sir
okay all right I don't like that you're
by this dog but okay
blue scores like I say anything back
yeah well see I'm gonna find a cozy
goddess walking sure enough hello dick
no God no oh that's what the jiggling
was clear up soon I imagine okay it's
awfully loud in here fruit
I don't like that I don't like the sad
take time
thank your joy yeah where's if
somebody's mentioned where's my stuff
can I get my stuff with my stuff no give
me my stuff
so from here I've gotta get us in
George's home and then into the parade
well except that I'll need a letter of
transit to get into the parade my desk
in the parade
what how do I get a new one what's my
star flight the old government printing
office was on a heightened home maybe I
can break in and steal something likes
my stuff but myself I didn't know I got
a key Gordon my stuff lovely day for it
where's my stuff Oh what the hell that
constable duh
sir lovely out where is it my stuff ah
my stuff the ah oh you guys are just
gonna be here forever aren't you sure is
weird without all the music gonna go
how's he gonna go and pretend like
nothing better
anybody got a place where I can jack off
that's the only thing I've wanted to do
hey how's it going I wasn't
fine oh those just don't like it when
you run Oh No
lovely day for it did you hear the
circus is coming to town oh that was so
weird though the the way they've run oh
god they say you see the oddest shadows
in the street at night I never look
lovely
father McCartney preaches such
thoughtful sermons I wish he was
Anglican okay hi Antonia
take down
[Music]
somebody's alarm
that's so funny Oh trouble here Oh Oh
God no please from an unfortunate blow
to the head loves to play tennis ah
that's nice leave behind an uncle Norton
Keynes 55 of st. George home
we all wish him well on his holiday and
look forward to his return yeah I'm sure
you do I'm sure you do this is so funny
so funny the old ladies Oh downer like
that's her alarm that's so funny all
right
anyway back into it back into the real
deal here don't get spot just in my feet
perfect Oh
what did you say to me I don't want a
cup or anything do do de de de de de not
this way Lily I guess I shouldn't go
scrounging around the waste bin either
seems like a lot of people are out for
lunch or on holiday um I'm sure that in
reality those are all like boarded up
like everything everything is horrible
that must be like the what this actually
L because I for it otherwise Oh
Jax's does II now I'm sure that
everybody in here is no better off than
the wastrels I think that's probably the
reality of what's happening here
toxic fog I'm going through it you'll
want to have a gas mask wet top that's
all there is to it then look duck did it
oh excuse me sir oh god okay excuse me
sir a lot a little eat the toxic fog
what are you doing Punk you were jumping
in a puddle most islands have
shopkeepers that sell helpful items and
marked on your map
oh I'm fine no no I'm I'm good where do
I go oh look look I'm not a no need to
be upset
I'm fine are you fine cuz I'm fine no no
I'm not a downer what are you doing
there we go okay oh I'm up here now shut
okay get me oh hi bonk what does that
mean
ow why did you have to throw a rock at
my head
okay what a minute I'm gonna die again
because I obviously like lost my job too
quickly over there that's totally fine
I'm sure this won't negatively affect me
in the long run so I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna fall over I wasn't running
I was I was only running when it was
time to run which is when I ran out of
joy duh duh duh duh I don't know where
is my joy
do I have joy did they give me joy was I
supposed to get joy I feel like I was
supposed to get something when I left
that place I felt like I maybe should
have gotten something I feel like maybe
they were supposed to give me something
Dagobah like in Star Wars diseases that
dated lovey therefore X we must we must
we must catch up sometime but not Dao I
bet they totally have you think we wear
the same size that's the most
interesting thing that you have to say
alright so I didn't have time to run
around an office he's pretty well
buttoned up oh no oh no oh no okay so
was it through this alleyway because
otherwise I'm gonna run out of joy and
I'm gonna have a lot of trouble here oh
crap oh crap oh crap I bet I was
supposed to get joy I feel like I was
supposed to get some joy I don't have
any joy here this one yeah this one yes
no not this one
oh well um Oh what now I can do it wait
next week
Arthur after hasting lovely go for it
lovely day for it me you idiots me
salary I knew it was you I mean the
glass is the hair they're really
adorable jacket don't ask me how you're
not that awkward little boy anymore I
ever the way you walk it's like the mask
isn't even no I just I just knew there's
a stir Sally you look fantastic
this ancient thing I've had it two weeks
I'm out of mine with boredom green and
white checked your dress the last time I
saw you running out the door good that
takes you back
you're off your joy oh don't be
ridiculous
uh II have little [ __ ] faith I'm not
gonna turn you in whatever possessed you
to go if your joy Parsi i saw a picture
of him
I promised I'd look after him in Germany
I have to go and find him
how are you gonna get out you even have
a letter of transit absolutely on my
desk in the city your Christ just tell
the policeman that I'm sure that wave
you're right on three yeah haven't
figured that out yet I'm very close with
general ping of course you are
no you always did have a knack for
making helpful new friends I mean I
could go see him and ask him to give you
a letter of transit don't put the
general out on my account
I'm sure you've only so many favors you
can ask of him my god he still hate me
don't you yeah
well I've only been wandering for the
past 14 years was 16 could you because I
liked him because he had that adorable
beard I know there isn't a reason for
everything you're the last bloody person
he should be off his joy I can't believe
you are believe me take enough stuff
look some downer broke into my lab last
week literally to all the bars of the
windows and the ridiculous thing is I
forgot to lock the front door the point
is it's a horrible terrible world out
there I just don't see you smashing your
way into the city without a great deal
of help oh no not me I really think on
the kingsroad me no of course you are I
couldn't exactly have stayed there I
could I I think nothing happened look
I'm sorry this isn't what I meant to
maybe we could help each other maybe I
could come by when I'm feeling better
brilliant
hmm she's Batman yeah what are they
talking about I don't even know so Hoss
how about going to the kingsroad
knocking on our door and apologizing
grievously and asking nicely for a
letter of transit
she knows general Bing whoa hey score
score bird we're a friend the mist boils
in air
funny you don't seem all or you might
say perhaps we can express our feelings
a pipe mist oil to her friend what did i
do what did I do to you I would have
punched the [ __ ] out of you get ready
for ow oh my god wait okay this is going
much poorer than I thought I would
I'm gonna grad don't you dare I'm gonna
get you
okay I might die on this one hang on I
need to take this excuse me while I
shove some healing balm in my eyes where
did you come from
aha oh wow
geez ohms got him in the head if I get
him in the head I've got that bonus okay
geez oh wait I do have something wait
when did I get a cricket back what did I
get
oh god I don't need to use that I think
I do oh god oh god oh god I like the
cricket bat less oh oh I'm dead
okay well I'm dead okay that guy's dead
I'm dead okay I couldn't heal anything
at all anyway well that was so weird
I'm sorry that was my bad being terrible
at that but don't worry about it
I got this oh so what did I do to you
guys I was friends with Sally apparently
when I was 16 and she cheated on me or
something but then again that's like DOS
so so long so who cares who cares
God you emotional prick I guess if
everyone's been forgetting everything
since then it's like well wasn't there a
war going on wasn't there more to worry
about just a bit of a sit-down a choice
oh I guess I'm done with that I don't
know too long why do long let did he do
did he ever do damn joy takers I know
right why are you so tall well well the
former basketball players just decided
to pay pretty well button up babe if
there's a way in the back there's a way
in right now apparently that's so weird
that it is legend aah Oh God Oh No what
are you
oh thanks there we go skip
[ __ ] about ghosts or here we go Punk no
skipper here we go now I'm gonna get you
mom look at the happiness they're
drinking tomorrow oh thank you
yeah you do he's dead why are they all
these people dead why they're dead yeah
whatever
don't matter to me little over there we
go alright well I got some joy at least
let me take up pop a squeaky pillow this
I want a glug some of this down lug some
more that's a good stuff let me just
like a sandwich down which looks a lot
like a pie all right we're all good
popjoy no no no mmm no that is the good
stuff all right what am i doing Oh put
the weapon away look there that uh
escape the Plowboys what was that you're
supposed to run away oh no nothing you
need to worry about constable Ola just
beyond my wife and where is it you're on
your way to precisely just enough to see
an old friend on San Jorge oh well
no needs me in such a hurry the bridge
to Sir Georges sir under renovation Oh
[Music]
for how long I hesitate to prognosticate
sir dr. paradise the only one who knows
that effects the ridiculous contraptions
on them bridges word has been sent but
we've not had the courtesy reply while
on you were I don't know go to dr.
Faraday's house because dr. F is removed
to a secret location the location which
headquarters keeps aa secret ah Loski
headquarters then you some kind of
trouble my gun state business you know
looks very happy go make up with son
I wanted to get dr. Faraday to come fix
his bridge so I need to visit please
headquarters and find out where he's
gone not now risk it all why is there a
pole dancing pole with Sally do you have
to complicate you jelly Oh probably
scotch what happened to him he's been a
solid citizen long as I've been on this
beach today he's going on about leaving
Hamlin waving around a suitcase like a
rotten downer well we can't have that
don't know where he thought he was going
nobody goes to the Garden District down
after maybe had relatives across the
bridge ha ha that's right there's been
an outbreak of relatives across the
bridge in an outbreak of Downers no of
course not
there's nothing to worry about that's a
relief
I'm sure the joy is just as good as he's
ever been these batch just gets better
and better
hey you keep taking it you'll take care
of you right okay what about scotch I
want you to have this Wow okay whoa
problem much what the hell man
this is an unexpected surprise what the
[ __ ] man don't that's horrible that's so
bad for you though the whole bottle dude
you're gonna die don't you chug that the
[ __ ] you okay did I do I need to call
somebody for you holy [ __ ]
ah the [ __ ]
oh and he's just uh all right whoa whoa
whoa buddy
uh-oh buddy Oh buddy constable concept
okay all right I'm just gonna go take
his back I don't want his bad I don't
want it back
oh good whoa take it from me stay inside
of the door I'm not too far away it's
kind of look did it
I'm gonna try to not want you let me
save actually okay nevermind I can't
save barely I'm gonna not take more joy
and I'm just gonna see if I can kind of
like oh why am I am i running why am i
running can I not run not running would
be great
can I not run I just I'm just going a
little bit faster than everybody else
was there like a button to walk cuz this
is gonna be a problem if I can't even
walk uh no a barely hidden hot keyboard
mapping here we go
walk caps-lock let's just make that a
toggle okay let's try that okay toggle
hi you know I do I take it I take it a
lot oh not looking there just oh wait
yeah I'm taking it I got it I'm good
look good don't they love doing leather
god that's weird
waffle iron for Louisville Luke I
thought you said cuz they caught [ __ ]
Jack and I'm like jeez that's quite a
name
this is reputation live up to his name
yeah whatever hey I'm attempting to
locate a Faraday not opposed you tell me
where I can find him I'm afraid that
information is not for public
consumption
oh they tell him where to find Bobby
Higginbotham though I for Evans sake
he's not in a Reform club again is it he
was supposed to go to Lud's own who
apparently feel so guilty
dr. F has been deprived of the liberties
which are the birthright of every
English citizen he's gotta get his ass
spanked constable Bevan I'm not the
public I'm from the Department of
Archives printing and recycling we're
conducting an investigation into dr.
Faraday's handling of municipal records
relating to the maintenance of the inter
insular bridges two requests have
already been sent by miss Byng to your
superior requesting this information if
I have to go back to the parade miss
beans next letter regarding this
apparently deliberative estimates will
include the name that the last person I
talked to well that'd be you constable
well the chap who keeps the
Constabulary's address book in that case
sir why don't you take the elevator on
Apso records they'll show you that thank
you oh sure thank you thank you whose
shoes oh god I thought someone was just
tapping behind me today made all the
bridges I literally thought someone was
just like behind me it was just like I'm
gonna turn around and there's just it's
gonna be a surprise and I don't I won't
like it okay alright finding Faraday
O'Day tube everywhere there a
pole-dancing tree oh I get it that makes
sense okay anybody see me
okay whoa I can pick it off
doo-doo-doo-doo can I have that no I
took it okay is it not oh it's also in a
way odd rush something you think you
will never forget
but then I suppose you do I'm author of
the high-stakes memories played tricks
on you do they know nope no no no way
[Music]
lovely day for it it's a lovely day and
I'm having a great day little letter
can't go through these okay
dodo duck Duck Duck tired about I but I
Babu said I'll okay no one here I didn't
know that was there holy [ __ ]
grandma sweets Germany coming back knows
they won't say anything just shut it
Persie just shuts it sorry till the
war's over
I guess the radio the radio keeps
talking about victories yes buts
the victories keep getting closer to
Berlin I can't hear you they keep
winning but then going back doesn't make
any sense
yeah it doesn't they're lying people
shouldn't lie it infuses everything yes
hmm
all right well okay then I don't know
what's that just in a locker
are there memories like that that are
just strewn about it whoo-hoo hey buddy
well before I lose my uh I wasn't doing
anything mr. bacon Kevin I love you died
for it oh there's buttons over here -
okay that's what I was looking for gimme
gimme gimme
daddy gonna pick this lock nobody's
seeing [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] okay well there's
no point in that
dude okay how bad is it gonna be if I go
over here hey buddy
hello constable Bevin said you all the
chapel where's dr. Faraday's current
address that's right
I've got records of everyone's address
back there all alphabetical I'm quite
proud of it so where was dr. Faraday
relocated to oh I can't tell you that
you're not a constable I guess it would
take two of you to make one constable if
you had platform shoes Yeah right anyone
else you'd like me to not tell you the
address on your very helpful that's what
everyone says you know I used to patrol
the street it was lovely
shopkeepers give you sandwiches ladies
flirt the warm Sun on your coat and one
misstep and they put you in the records
room it's hardly fair
you want some birds you want some bows
I got bows do you want bows uh your
booze you think you're going there no
we're not going anywhere
almost oh I'm fine
don't look at me now Oh
Lindsay nothing Doolittle
[Music]
just go on the rear finding Faraday
I like the alliteration in that that's
definitely good I'm not gonna take my
joy no oh god I said I wasn't smoking
super-cold a drug boy wasn't maybe I can
find those two F's address myself every
day I said I wasn't and then what did I
do
oh oh no nothing no liar rah rah rah rah
rah rah rah rah rah rah rah rah rah rah
rah rah
[Applause]
yeah just rest in the loot ah mother
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine everything's fine all good
here it's all good so I got it Boop
good this guy missable Hastings first of
all hast a surprise no it's not oh my
head
you back you back on ball
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
wait hang on hello I don't live in said
you will the chapter wait a minute wait
hang on let me get somewhere safe hang
on wait a minute wait that guy the guy
thought I was Percival the guy thought I
was Percival the voices don't sound
right Percival sounded older than Arthur
who is apparently the guy I'm playing as
but that's not that's not how it went no
he didn't just he didn't just
impersonate he didn't just say lie about
his birthday he took his brother's car
because they look different in the
picture this is this is Percival that's
why that guy mistook him for birth this
is Percival
he took his older brothers card
alphabetical but that guys the reasons
that guy thought he was Percival is
because he showed him that card which
had Percival on it so this this is
Arthur but he lied about his brother
that's why that guy he didn't just oh he
[ __ ] his brother over hard he took it
cuz he knew that his brother was
mentally disabled in some way autistic
or something and couldn't like
rationalize back and no one would
believe him that's why the that's why
the voice age didn't sound right okay I
gotta go Faraday which is right here Oh
lovely of famous kids in here somewhere
Oh
[Music]
Oh not that you can be you kidding me
you yanking on me certainly does place
organized dr. Faraday's in lots home
that's crazy why and how do I get
someone's home
well they renovating you what happens if
there's like another filing cabinet that
I can see here oh I'm off withdrawal hey
that's good then I'm fine oh all good
ever I can fake it I can't fake being in
here though but that that makes so much
more sense because that oh that explains
so much okay but all mogudu so let's get
EOD let's go back you out II did it okay
how do I get over there there wasn't
like another way out there was there
turn it on that time up a little bunk
okay that's cool
okay that's cool alright I get it I get
it I get it what dr. niller walking real
slow we won't we
okay man this is slow lovely day for it
Bobby he came both he's supposed to
check up on dr. Faraday but he's at the
Reform club instead get his ass spanked
he must have some sort of ID that lets
in Causton Lud's hole maybe I could
borrow it
okay so this place does look all nice
and stuff so that that medicine can't
exactly was
sorry I didn't mean to make you get up
no I didn't hear about Ross constables
Rossetti's wife's cake how is it is that
a euphemism no I don't you don't know
that so what is oh that's like a
television thing that detects that so I
need to avoid those but as far as that
goes I can just walk around all happy do
P I could probably run just fine Oh what
the hell hello weird alright well okay
thank you for that I'm just gonna go now
bizarre I don't think they'd mind if I
just do this quicker run this is
probably fine alright hey yo DV that's
why Sally's able to like not take and be
fine oh sorry lovely day oh my God he's
still drunk you all right dude you're
gonna be drunk for the next 10 years if
you don't die literally immediately you
still you okay alright well he seems to
be fine also where do they can recruit
all these tall [ __ ] where do they
recruit them all is this just like
everyone of a certain height gets to be
a constable and that's the only thing
that you get oh oh oh whoa whoa okay
there's a TV oh [ __ ] okay so maybe if I
walk under those that will be okay but
if I walk directly in front of them
probably not good
the English Vice
lovely day for thank you thank you
Club this is where that chap is supposed
to be getting spanked isn't he the one
with the credentials for crossing the
bridge sir lot halt
I have been modest feeling in this place
like I should come back maybe not during
the day
oh no oh no this is it oh no oh this
isn't what we own oh oh it's oh it's a
BDSM Club oh that is one hundred percent
of BDSM Club I would be willing to put
money that this is a BDSM Club full of
happiness and joy and spankings yeah
that's a BDSM Club that is 100 percent
easily a BDSM Club how many times can i
say BDSM Club alright we're gonna go
take a nap
if I got a bed I can crash in and I
sleep here on the ground
can I just nap oh hey oh that's weird
okay Oliver's office Wow there's nothing
in there where can I take a nap there
place like I can fast travel to house
can I go to house what happens if I go
to house can I go to house kind of go to
house house what happens if I go can I
fast travel to anywhere no I can't all
right well I'm gonna try to go to house
I don't know our house is gonna do fine
we'll go a house cuz I just need to be
able to sleep right that's the only
thing I need to do just find a bad sleep
it away gonna be good lovely day for it
lovely day for it I look very happy me
oh you know me look I'm full of joy
lovely dinner alright nobody seems to
mind it's only when you're like
withdrawing from it that's what's bad
okay
right here no yes oh well hello no oh I
gotta be into it okay a spanker you you
suspect lady
you saw spanker Spanky downer by spanker
what do you what do we mean by spanker
what can you cut lady can you clarify
your words about it why you thought us
banker was lovely anyway gonna go steal
somebody's bed anybody in there Oh
is there oh there is somebody in there
well they're never gonna know huh hey
hey hey let's see about pickin this lock
I don't think is there a way to just
wait where I am is it like a Skyrim
thing where I can just wait wherever I
go can I save also can I please thank
you my goodness I haven't saved in ages
okay let's dude oh it seems to be your
family in here yes hello hi ma'am
whoa awfully drafty in here huh okay
Lottie I'm tres pansy I just gotta find
your bed whoo no you didn't see nothing
just going to the bed steal you me I'm
sure you've got a free bed it's perfect
I'll sleep there
oh yeah and uh nine uh there we go and
sleep why do you woke up they realize
did it or just being a bad dream I just
took a five-hour nap in here talking
about
what I want
what are you our lady huh I just wanted
a nap you kidding me
you let me sleep in peace I guess you've
got better things to do than chase the
guy that just ran into your house and
slept in your bed
I wonder who's gonna be in this bed lady
are you doing lady go to bed go to bed
already
but Tempus Fugit what does it even mean
it was Lily what are you doing it what
go to bed what God abandoned what are
you doing lady got a panda what are you
thinking it's got a bad way of pacing oh
you don't even need to worry about all
the troubles of the world you've got a
bad whatsit Tempus Fugit all right I'm
gonna try sneak out while she goes the
other way okay you Inc okay
crouch whooping
okay then sneaky out the back a Dory and
it's like nothing ever happened
perfect save that one perfect day
perfect oh okay so I just got a voice a
bob boze bobble so he's walking the
other way okay
all right we're good all right so we
just got to make our way away from the
baubles the baboso
ain't gonna get no thing of me that
toxic gas why is there why is there an
exorbitant amount of toxic gas
oh oh oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I always wonder what happened to
the letters there was an old full of
smoke
uh-oh that's a bobble you'll never catch
me because I'm hidden you'll never catch
me oh they caught me um you'll never
catch me
total actor you'll never catch me never
ever catch me you'll never catch me
you'll never know Africa Loulou
god save the queen what happened to the
Queen does anybody know oh I don't know
okay oh hey buddy listen pal okay this
is gonna be ah [ __ ] oh wow [ __ ]
um ah [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay listen you can't see me you
could never see me you can't see me I'm
so hidden you cannot see me oh he sees
me and he doesn't see me just like that
just like that baby just like that no
watch he's gonna spot me now I will
watch this [ __ ]
just like that baby just like that okay
oh you you real dum-dum ain't you oh you
real dum-dum
oh you big dum-dum me I'm big smart man
there way like through this alley no way
like behind yeah there is
oh you know there is oh you know there
is oh wait that guy's standing in front
of whoa they're still dead
oh no he's no there ain't no you know
there ain't you know you know there
ain't [ __ ] okay just got a sneaky stone
key sneaky stalk him on it just watch
he's needy don'tyou don't know nothing
you don't know nothing watch cuz he's
gonna look over
oh what was that huh weird huh
easy-peasy
Oh lemon my squeezy okay he's gonna just
go right by me ain't goin no know
nothing about me oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
I'm not gonna kill them why would I kill
them
why would I want to kill them look at
them and they're so tall I'm they need
to live to breed so that we get more
tall people at home I what up I don't
have nothin uh what what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna go through this oh why didn't all
I wasn't supposed to go oh well [ __ ] me
then I'm just gonna go through it [ __ ]
it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
well no listen oh hey listen listen
listen listen listen listen
absolutely unnecessary absolutely
disgraceful
don't turn around don't turn around
perfect excellent close that up
never mind only its banks why are you
spent so badly I don't exactly have an
invitation as such just healthy
curiosity oh okay fine um well [ __ ] find
a way in okay how about this window okay
that's as easy as that
oh no not me me oh can I hide in here
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right you're gonna
get your wallet go wild you you you want
yours walloping wallet wallet wallet
so oh [ __ ] you're red but I don't like
this I like this I don't like this I'll
argue hey listen uh yogurt
okay wait watch watch watch and I've
done I am the greatest - oh he knows
okay no II don't know you might not know
whoa oh you're a stinky one ancient oh
you're a stanky
Oh your stanky ancient
he's a big Stanko oh he's stanky okay
Oh brake lever I'm pretty clever I don't
know how that guy figured me out that
was snow snows weird like the guy he
should have liked it shouldn't have been
that way but it was you know what I mean
it shouldn't have been like that but it
do hmm
all right okay all's Quiet on the
Western Front almost not yet though
Apple I'm a big hyung go oh hey buddy
okay I'm gonna take this cuz I'm a big
hurt Oh - can I make more of that I
thought I'd got a lot of those things
antiseptic bandage I don't know what
that does but can i craft up some more I
can get another Slap Chop okay um you're
healthier buff weapons subsequent
particulates damage for most attacks
that's nice where's my where's my
fisting ability I want to be able to
fish real good I just want to fist the
best smooth talker oh really
shove someone in glue oh yes tippy toes
[Music]
tippy toes
of course I want tippy toes I want tippy
toe oh you people ignore your annoying
habits oh but I want that that's I
wanted running jump all over the place
I'm gonna get in here ah dah I can't
wait for that oh I'm gonna get that so
good what I'll wait what no wait what
wait wait what oh here we go
okay there's someone over here I don't
know why oh hi oh okay all right well
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay what's up what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the food that the
flying [ __ ] was that the would that why
did the person from inside run over
there I didn't kill anybody
I didn't kill nobody I didn't kill
nobody
I didn't kill nothing I didn't do
nothing to nobody nothing I didn't do
nothin from nobody I didn't it wasn't my
fault I got it's gonna be morning by the
time I get in there
don't turn around don't turn around
player you dare
what why are you there why would you be
there what what what what what what are
you blowing bubbles
you are what what I'll go in the other
window then oh hi um how are you
floating are you you real okay
wait I just saw it I saw what I wanted I
saw I saw it hang on wait where's I I
just saw it all Oh No
oh there we go wrap your entire body and
rubber reduces electrical shock alarms
anyone who's not a rubber fetishist not
a perv in this suit at least I'll fit in
among pervs
on the other hand to protect me against
electricity and lightning and things hmm
finally oh I feel it I feel safe in my
own skin
Oh welcome me somebody spanked me
somebody please somewhere please spank
me spank me spank me constable Rawlinson
spank me lovely day for it yeah that's
more like it
I was almost thinking you were not one
of us Oh it's almost like you've saw me
before
lovely day for it anyway
just gonna Crouch it oh hey hi should
clear up soon I imagine
okay that's gonna you can't see me right
definitely not no way I don't like the
heavy breathing I hear I'm so sneaky so
god damn sneaky memory dude I don't even
know what happened I don't even
understand see they said he got painting
at school yes did it hurt very much no
are you sure you're gonna be all right
yes do you understand why why you what
well boy you got the caning yes
did you really kick a rubbish bin in
Silesia Carlton's face no I didn't write
d do you kick a rubbish bin yes did it
then go in celesta Cotton's face i I
didn't see him I didn't see him he came
around the corner he came around he came
around the corner oh that's not one oh
good
are you being sarcastic yeah I was being
sarcastic I hate it when you're
sarcastic no all right so that's just
more memories of back then and I haven't
gotten any money in a while I don't have
a safe cracker
should I go this way again I don't like
the heavy breathing I'm here in coarse
linen why would anyone want course linen
new rubber cat suit why is it a cat suit
is there a difference between a cat suit
and not a cat oh no it's all rubber cat
suit big splinter okay then why is this
so stinky here oh boy
it was having so much fun no it's they
have a way to take people out of
commission without killing them oh
that's nice yeah I got that now
apparently okay cool I guess hey buddy
come on now loot your dead body
raw meat why did something tells me that
raw meat I don't want something tells me
that the raw meat I got from the man in
a rubber cat suit in a bathtub with an
electrical device and a bunch of satanic
ritualistic candles and a doc isn't the
kind of raw meat that I want to eat
taking this duck take it here all right
gotta go on search the toilet why not
okay I did that all right where am I
going
candy candy pinata pinata
[Music]
this guy's dead this doesn't make any
sense doesn't make any sense everyone's
dead I'm gonna get banned how do you
band here I'm gonna get banned there's
too much going on over there oh yeah you
had that coming all right okay I don't
want to suppose I'm gonna get bad I
didn't do this I'm gonna get banned I'm
gonna get banned I'm gonna get banned oh
I'm getting banned I'm so banned
oh I'm gonna get banned oh I'm gonna get
banned I keep looking at it I should
look away I could look away at any time
I could look away at any moment but I'm
still looking
why am I looking but why do I keep
watching this I'm still watching I'm
still looking at it is there a number I
can take and I'll be the next I don't
know I could push this button at any
moment put it away and never see it
again but nope here I am still here okay
gonna push that button okay all right
well I am very the old paper all right
is there was there more I haven't known
the other way okay hey oh it's James all
right what's going on over here oh right
I could take his stuff and then I can
walk across the bridge to Lutz home with
his credentials car knife
well should I look in it's probably not
the best idea to search his body right
now
hope got a bobby pin from Bobby
Hickenbottom didn't bother madam bobby
pin how to punish me oh okay how to
punish me I am so sorry about bursting
into tears the other night it was truly
inappropriate when you were doing such
fine work with the path to hope I'm
sorry it's like reading fanfiction here
I'm sorry I objected to being swaddled
after especially as it was my stupid
idea to have you sing take the key and
lock him up my fair lady
I just meant it to be generally mocking
you know it wasn't supposed to bring up
old feelings of myself let alone you
it'll be very grateful if you would
punish me very harshly tonight
please accuse me of being a truly wicked
man I've done things to an innocent
person
please accuse me of being a coward for
not leaving the Constabulary a real man
would do the right thing and go off to
blackberry
please accuse me of being a liar for
pretending to forget a real man with
faces nightmares Thank You mistress
Wanda for giving us a safe in private
place what would I do without you your
devoted servant Bobby Hickenbottom oh
boy very sorry very sorry very sorry
oh what Oh what
what's a [ __ ] what the phew [ __ ] gang
all right you know I think we wear the
same size okay all right then
the rumpus room the rumpus room
oh hell the rumpus room I'm going into
ruck and I get this party hat all right
what's in the runt do I want to know
okay we're not going in the rudder
rumpus room
mm miss yeah hard pass no of course no I
want you to stop talking oh it's our key
please I don't wanna know I don't know
anything to do with them damn
okay all right this room seems okay
zap night
Uncle Jack says watch out for this -
lovely day for it such good comedic
timing on these zaps
alright well I guess I'm gonna zap them
all out and then steal whatever's in
this chest huh
you should stay down so I don't like the
moaning don't like the moaning no don't
like the moaning ooh torch don't take
that I guess don't like the moaning
right in the armpit okay there you go
have a good day wait there's another one
over here
I gotta reach right in the dick okay all
right square in the dick there we go all
right got you there all right don't
worry I got you buddy
I think I don't got you I got you buddy
all right you guys have save your
moaning for another day you've really
done you've done a bang-up job over here
you've done it you've done it ah [ __ ]
okay I don't know where the where that
other objective was but uh this person
isn't this person no they're unconscious
oh I thought they were dead okay anyway
I like that Alright stern governess okay
no this isn't hot no is anybody in chat
is enjoying this stop it
oh boy but I don't look good is this
where I was supposed to get this stuff
what that is all about okay Phoenix
Mondays knickers Tuesdays spankings
Wednesdays naughty nurses Thursdays
pony-play
Fridays quilting also breath control
Saturdays wet room Sundays penitence and
redemption yeah where do I see my quests
this one
Madam's magic wand she's lost her locker
key I wonder where it is this doesn't
show me where it is tits up that was
good okay all right well I don't know
where oh I got a loose screw from a
loose clock
so it's not in these it's not in that
one
what locker are you talking about hey
can I go other feelings then you might
not be to your taste why don't you go
away I should come back entirely covered
in rubber since when was that but I am
I'm entirely covered in rubber are you
talking about I'm tired I'm covered in
rubber what I am yeah rock proved well
suppose I should come back in tightly
covered in rubble what [ __ ] how do
you keep doing that how the [ __ ] do you
keep doing that Marvin what the [ __ ]
okay whatever I don't know why that's
that but I I'm gonna go back upstairs
because I don't know where else to go
cuz it's got to be something with the
madam right also is it just me or is it
not quite smooth frame rate everything
seems to be fine over a magic wand
McAdoo stars are sort of unbreakable
head NACA probably not okay where is it
yeah where was it where did you say it
was was it in here is it in here I don't
want to go searching through your stuff
if you're gonna be pissed off but I'm
gonna do it alright sure whatever if
they could stop moaning outside that
would be wonderful
oh wait who's this there's some kind of
electrical cable there I'm sure they
wouldn't make that yellow if they didn't
sign oh no wait a minute wait there's
something here this is supposed to move
or this could move there's something
here there's something there yeah that's
going up to that so this can move maybe
yeah I don't know why but it doesn't
even like the frame weight is 100%
smooth right now I've been getting bad
frame rate lately in games I don't know
why
oh sorry ah so I okay well can I load
the game wait are you just screaming at
my way
[Music]
I have no idea what okay what the hell
is this okay open trap panel ah I don't
have a short spike okay I don't know
what what am I supposed to do don't we
just agree to disagree
[Laughter]
she's got no legs he's got no legs he's
got no legs
she's got no ceiling
[Laughter]
I'm sorry look at the look every man I'm
sorry I didn't know you'd go so I you're
much lighter than you look I gotta go
from downtown yeah I got this one Coby
he'll be gonna ever get everybody
together you gotta think of don't worry
I'm not gonna get it I'm gonna get it
okay call me you fly too high
why do you fly so high call me
there we go all right I'm sorry I'm just
having fun with that all right I'm gonna
go reload the game from the main menu
because that obviously didn't go as I
was hoping it was gonna go but it went
really well for what it was an okay
we're gonna continue I think it probably
will continue where where's my mouse
okay select game maybe there we go there
we go okay let's do this one that's
funny though I already have the freaking
key no I don't when did I get the key
did I get the key
do not have the key I guess I didn't try
to open it
that was my bad oh if I had the key then
I'm sorry I'm a big dumb dummy do but
you know whatever okay then I'm gonna
try if this if this just opens over okay
hey where am I
God brilli here wherever here is where
is this what the [ __ ]
oh I'm outside it alright whatever okay
sure what where where what the boy why
did way where do you come from
wow what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] I'm not gonna take my joy Oh gah
gah well hi listen listen listen listen
listen
that's so annoying why did that guy that
guy was just floating him in there
forever and then now he decides that he
boy has a problem with me yeah well I'm
gonna die cuz I don't have enough
anything I'm gonna die hello died that's
that's all there is to it wait I'm gonna
I'm just gonna die so I might as well
just go over here get walloped in the
face I'm trying to I'm wearing a cat
suit I'm very rubberized
I'm very rubberized and someone else
wall at me ball at me
you have where who are you looking at
who are you you looking that guy
what them what did he do to you don't
know not a bow okay there I go no no no
way
I am we're gonna go back into it I don't
know why that was that way that it was
cuz that guy was a douche
I had my catsuit on I did any don't
think even that mattered cuz at this
point it should have been all should
have been all hunky Dukey but I don't
know the saving in this game doesn't
really work the way it's supposed to and
I don't know why yeah
just rest in the feet jus you more free
all right where am i okay here we go
we're gonna go okay now that guy is down
on the ground
that's okay okay so this guy's gonna be
a problem
that easy huh oh
okay couldn't be better thanks Iran yeah
rotten to come back entirely covered in
rubber but I am covered in rubber very
delighted to see you always nice to meet
a new friend of a bit of a feeling this
venue might not be to your taste I
should come back in toilet car I found
ways to break this game man
somehow I just want to get up into that
place so I can see if I have the key
which maybe I do but now I don't even
think that it I don't even think that
it's supposed to be in the place where
it says it's gonna be in the game I
don't know why whatever it's fine I'm
fine it's fine here we go god dammit
alright it's fine
everything's fine everything's good
Marvin Flitz Fitz
Lloyd Griffith Jones what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you okay ma'am ma'am ma'am
wait this
no that's wait wait I didn't have it um
[Music]
okay oh boy I've she's dead she's dead
she's dead I'm gonna go back we're gonna
go back we're gonna go back I don't
maybe that was the wrong save can't have
been right right that can't be right
now is that right that can't be right
that cannot be right there's no way
that's right
there's no way that's right nuh-uh-uh
okay alright hang on no I sigh very
meticulously oh my god all of them wait
all of them are the exact same picture
no that's not right
why are you there no wait oh that's a
camper oh no oh oh if I look in the
bushes over here okay that's that's one
great lady okay I think it's okay I
don't see r0 hold it up back now we're
gonna go in here I'm gonna go upstairs
and everything's gonna be fine you know
why cuz I know the timestamps this is
obviously not I didn't save after I
killed her you know what I mean okay
there's still a loose screw in there I
didn't save after I killed her that must
have been like an autosave or something
I think this one's gonna be fine
this one's gotta be good this was
everything fine hello there she is
hey lady are you doing madam Wanda no
sir magic wand
unbreakable head knocker usual fooled
okay alright so I got it
everything's good the monsters are
spending Otto say okay we're gonna find
the magic wand show quest on map okay
find the hats shocking revelation where
would it be
visit house where is it where is it
where is it that it what's in his
suitcase is that what the thing is is
that what's in his suitcase or is that a
different thing what's in his suitcase
that must be it
oh it must be where that guy is uh okay
oh I'm gonna get that I want to get that
excuse me Bob Denham Wow oh good man
it's not curfew is it not the beer I'm
gonna go for that no I'm done fooling
around - I gotta get to where I need to
get why can i still hear them saying
punished why are they still saying
punish me why is that still a thing why
is it so thing I don't like that wait uh
over here
okay one more down no one saw a thing
I'm in my rubber suit
no one knows no one can know no one will
know no one knows no one ever knows okay
it's over there
that guy's still drunk but if I just run
in and grab it maybe I can be fine
yes try that I need to look in here yeah
oh oh [ __ ] I need to hold it down okay
ah come with me hang on come with me
hey okay over here
nobody knows nobody knows nobody knows
everybody knows come on oh wow oh my dad
no no no you're drunk
hang on no it's fine no no no hang on
wait hang on no no no yeah listen listen
listen buddy squaddies punishments pals
pals pals baths I wish I could run
faster but I can't no I didn't look in
the suitcase didn't look in the suitcase
it's fine it's fine
look hey guys this is nothing there's
nothing look see I'm fine
look at me it's all good don't worry
about it I'm gonna get this key I'm
gonna get the thing it's all maybe good
have you believed in me
remember to spin key spanked that sweet
like button if you think that I know
what I'm doing if you'd think if you've
got full confidence in me and you're
wearing your rubber cat suits at home
please give that like button a sweet
electrical shock ooh
punish that like button make it make
that Punnett that like buttons been a
bad boy and you need to who you need to
punish that like button who your guy oh
yeah that like funds been asking for it
all day oh yeah you're gonna you're oh
yeah you're gonna give it what it
deserves right right right right guys
you guys are gonna oh yeah I know I know
what you were saying yeah you did oh you
are and you were you did and you are and
you am all right anyway no it's fine
it's fine guys it's guys guys guys guys
guys it's fine well he knows shockingly
he knows
okay I'm gonna loop around I'm gonna I'm
gonna draw these guys away I'm not gonna
get hit hello listen listen listen
buddies buddies come this way wow that's
a lot of them okay that's fine
cama drawn drawn in draw them in draw
them this way go draw him out they're
gonna follow me yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
that's a lot that's a lot of them that's
a lot of meatballs okay then there's the
one that's drunk okay don't look in the
suitcase the suitcase I got it I got it
I got tits up down or done I don't know
what that was all about but I didn't get
the key
well now I don't know what you want from
me
what does it want from was this game
want from me what does it want from me
what do you want I'm in a rubber suit
I'm very uncomfortable I'm extremely
sweaty it really seals in the flavor of
it maybe you should go shut up for a bit
no you guys don't see nothing right you
guys wouldn't possibly be why would
someone be dead that doesn't make any
sense okay what a lot I picked this one
oh no oh no no no oh no oh no no I'm
fine
don't look at me don't look at me don't
look at me I'm fine all right
so there's gotta be something that I'm
missing right it's gotta be something
that I'm missing oh I did find it
I did find it it was in that bag Oh tits
up downer because I just gotta wait till
the heat drops off so it was in there it
was in there it was in there unless that
red means it's not good I don't know
what the hell that would mean then wait
why is this in red then oh wait what no
is she dead now oh did it looked oh did
it load the most recent oh no oh hi what
weird stuff happening is she oh no it
did it did it did god damn it she's in
the tree why are you in the tree why are
you in the where she Wow I hurt Mike's
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
okay I think that's a good enough place
as any to end it I'm all that time for
this one I'll just go stare at the crime
of what I've done
there we go that's that's perfectly
fitting okay so I got or just gonna end
it there that was good enough uh yeah so
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna pick this up again in
another episode I promise I'll make more
progress in the next episode I won't be
so focused on the fetishization of it
but how could I not when everything was
screaming and moaning in my ear it's in
the locker okay it's in the locker I'll
look in the locker but thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think in the comments
below if you don't want to punish that
like button then then go about your day
and have a have a lovely have a lovely
day without any mental scars or anything
to try to forget this at all
thank you everybody to join the channel
through the memberships thank you
everybody they gave through super chat
you are all wonderful you're all lovely
I am going to leave and try to pour
bleach directly into my eyeballs to
forget about everything that I just saw
so I recommend that you all do the same
thank you again punished so don't punish
the light punish the like button all
right thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
buh-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]